[Music]
joining me this week is a former
candidate for president of the United
States from the libertarian party and a
man who according to his Twitter bio is
Pro Liberty pro life and pro con stitute
Austin Peterson welcome to the Rubin
report thanks about me we've been trying
to do this for quite some time our clear
going to go bonkers my people of your
people I don't know if your people like
me yet but I guess that kinda remains to
be seen I think they're there I don't
know if you've noticed but there seems
to be a classical liberal libertarian
little bonding thing happening in
America right people said that if I get
you to say you're a smaller libertarian
they're gonna donate five bucks my super
PACs to it oh is that right so are your
libertarian we can you can turn some of
this on me at some point but are not
recognized yet not yet not just yet so
so it's funny I shooting three shows
today and I just walked outside with my
dog just to get some fresh air
I just found you wandering in the street
you didn't even take a car here you're
truly a man of the people
yeah well you know from Missouri grew up
on a farm pretty common you know and I
think that you know California land you
know they were trying to like the
environmentalists right maybe on
bicycles that's what I walk in found
your studio yeah all right so here we
are there's a lot I want to get to with
you but let's just start with the basic
people know I like definitions you ran
as a libertarian what is a libertarian
to you what a little essentially a
libertarian it allows you to choose your
own values as long as you don't try and
use the government to force those values
on somebody else and that's why we get a
lot of infighting in the libertarian
party because we have so many people
from so many different backgrounds with
different values but the one value we
all share is that we believe the
government should be limited so that
individuals can choose what they want to
do and choose their values and explore
the wide range of options you know
sometimes those options are dangerous
you know some people choose to smoke but
they should have the right to do that
as long as they don't try and impose a
cost onto others right and so as soon as
you start talking about you know what
sort of a cost people are imposing on
others that's when government starts to
come into the equation you know at the
most hardcore end of libertarianism you
know it which some say is
the truth libertarianism is it's anarchy
and uncle capitalism I think I fall
right before that yeah right I get okay
I'm right there I call myself a men
artists essentially the government
should be relegated very basic rules
they should protect life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness you know that may
include things like fire courts police
military otherwise the everything else
should be solved by the market yeah so I
had Brian Kaplan from George Mason
University who's an anarcho-capitalist
yeah I really an Oracle for summary yeah
brilliant guy and I thoroughly we did
about an hour and a half I enjoyed every
minute of it there were moments where I
thought all right this is a bit much of
some private court stuff and some of the
pacifism stuff and open borders right
but is that the inherent problem with
the libertarian party not the philosophy
but the party that this thing's really
wide and when you say I'm a libertarian
people see some of these guys or some of
the you know at the convention the guy
running around without a shirt some of
the more crazy pieces of the worst thing
that happened that I will get to that in
a second yeah but that it's Bay because
it's based on the individual it's hard
to get a whole bunch of individually
focused people to agree on something but
because essentially you're talking about
taking collective action right yes it's
kind of an Optima to the libertarian
cause but I mean the libertarian party
is made up of sincere individuals these
people really want limited government a
lot of these people are victims of the
state people that have been harmed
whether they've been persecuted in their
communities for doing things like
homeschooling or maybe they want to
drink raw milk right maybe they want to
have the ability to sell that right
honest farmers and things like that so
it's kind of easy to poke fun at the
people like the naked guy but but but
the thing is is that the news often
doesn't go in and cover the tales of the
single mothers who are being harmed
because their tax rates are so high that
it's hard for them to feed their kids
all right that doesn't make as
compelling a news story as the guy who
you know dances around so so there the
problem is is that you know we're
missing the forest for the trees in some
sense and there are a lot of sincere
dedicated activists in Libertarian Party
who really just want to they're not just
fighting for their own freedom and many
of them many of them are sincere
Patriots who are fighting for the
freedom of their fellow countrymen and
age
see the two parties as being one of the
same in some sense that they really that
their solutions are just more government
yeah that's what that's that's the kind
of untold story of the heroes of
Libertarian Party which we don't see
very often
okay so I want to spend most of our time
talking about looking forward but we do
have to look back a little bit here
right I mean to me 2016 was a massive
disaster for you guys because I've said
this a zillion times first of I voted
for Gary okay I've had Gary Johnson on
the show the candidacy ultimately was
just terrible and I think if there was
ever a year where the libertarians or
any third maybe the Greens whoever
although obviously I agree more with you
guys but if there was ever a year where
there is going to be a mark made not not
the presidency but a mark to be made
this was it there was so much discussed
yeah with Trump and Clinton what
happened well I'll tell you this topic I
mean this turns me into salt Bay like I
could draw but but you usually welcome
out the musket couldn't be able yeah the
fire the flintlock right yeah the boy
you're going to get my hackles up all
right so it's very difficult to be in
this situation we're in position of
having tried to stop that I having kind
of seen it there's nothing more
frustrating and I think a lot of
libertarians see this and so many other
ways on society as a whole where we see
things kind of rushing toward a cliff
and you're screaming stop and people it
if you're going to tell people the truth
you better make them laugh or else
they'll kill you and that's happening in
society but with the Libertarian Party
there were so many times when the
economy incompetence was being displayed
pre-primary and people either weren't
paying attention or they were applauding
it mm-hmm I mean there's videos of some
of the the gasps and stumbles and went
on before the convention and I don't
think there's an excuse I mean the
people who take responsibility for what
it was need to take responsibility
because they had every opportunity to
try and stop it and they sort of cheered
it on but you know the Libertarian Party
has a lot of the same problems that the
major two party has with cults of
personality and things like that and
with none of the upsides of actually
winning election that's right so that's
the problems of fighting in a third
party but is there a bigger issue here
we
is that forgetting the specific stumbles
that Gary made one forgot denomination
and again I like him as a person I think
he's a decent guy and I hope they'll
come back here and I'd be happy to
discuss all this stuff with him but is
that the bigger issue the only time
anyone ever talked about the
libertarians was when he either made a
gaffe or when the naked guy ran around
beyond that there was virtually no
coverage so it was almost as if you had
to do outlandish thing so I watched the
the libertarian debate right and I
thought they needed to say more crazy
things if anyone was going to pay
attention as even though I don't believe
that generally with the right apology
well it's you know it's not about what
you say it's about how you say it very
frequently right and so sometimes it was
just Gary's delivery that came off as
awkward it wasn't necessarily what he
was saying but the way that he was
saying it which I think puts people off
and the thing about Donald Trump that
was so attractive was that he was giving
the last year was a crazy bastard year
right and libertarians as crazy bastards
that could have been our year yeah and
with the rise of the alt-right which is
really what propelled in many ways but
helped propel Donald to the presidency a
lot of those people you know were
sincere conservatives who were looking
for a third option they wanted somebody
who could take down Hillary and I think
that the real strategy problem was
simply that it looked as if Gary and
Bill were sort of cozying up to Hillary
which is what nobody in the United
States wanted because they rejected her
so it wasn't so much what Gary was
saying it was it was it relied a little
bit more on tactics I mean gaba delivery
was not that good but and the gas were
horrible but it really just comes down
to not being able to read the political
winds of the of the time and that's
that's really where we suffered yeah
without getting too thick in the weeds
just the the machinations behind the
scene of the party because I don't think
people really understand like what
happens by the party so we know the
Democrats had this massive machine we
know it's deeply corrupt and that was a
lot of that has been exposed the
Republicans also have a pretty powerful
machine I don't think it's quite as
corrupt but who knows what is what is
the underpinnings of the libertarian
machine like what's going on behind the
scenes who's in charge what well that
nobody an archetype yeah yeah I mean
they have the libertarian National
Committee their job is to
run candidates for office I think the
good thing about the Libertarian Party
is that well anybody can participate
right they it's not like a Democrat so
they have super-delegates and things
like that anybody can become a delegate
if you join the Libertarian Party and go
to your state convention so the way that
the libertarian party works is it's
powered by the people there isn't you
know some shadowy coke money the Koch
brothers left years ago so it's really
just powered by the activists and the
people who want to try and see these
ideas be put into public policy now
there are some people who actually the
caucus with the party but they don't
want the party to actually win elections
for for multitude of reasons one being
perhaps that they think that there will
be a system-wide collapse and
libertarians will get blamed for it if
some if there's a libertarian president
and another one is that they think to
the party should be educational so
you've got all these different factions
in the party and and some of them are
students here committed activist who
really want to bring about change but
when it comes to the math nation's it's
what you see for the most part is what
you get I mean there are some backroom
dealings and things that go on and a lot
of pressure and hassling that goes on to
the convention people like you know
endorse little weld you know we'll give
you the world it's like that sort of the
Bible where like they think you medicine
Satan is like if you allow before me no
they will but but you know there's there
that kind of stuff happens but for the
most part it's what you see is what you
get
yeah was there a moment after Gary got
the nomination that you would have
considered being his VP or did they
announce once he got the nomination
today I say they were a team immediately
well of course that he was running to be
the VP and the thing was this you know
my mistakes that I made at the
convention was that I actually took the
principal moves over the pragmatic moves
and I'll just explain this very briefly
so there was a brief period of time when
some people said okay Austin if you want
just go run for the VP slot but because
I was trying to think for what the good
the party and for the good of ticket I
thought to myself okay well Gary hates
me and I wouldn't want to be hamstrung
by a VP that I can't stand but he
obviously wanted bill you know the the
delegates thought that he was better so
I was trying to I gave in to the will
the majority and I thought no I'm not
going to do this because
I think it's going to [ __ ] the ticket
well then later I stupidly I didn't
realize that Gary had threatened that if
he didn't get the weld he would quit
ha ha ha ha ha if I had weld in the veep
I would have been a candidate right if
Gary had quit so maybe I should have
just stuck it well I suspect he wouldn't
have chose you though right no but they
don't choose that's how the Libertarian
Party is different from the major
parties the delegates choose the vice
presidential candidate so if I really
wanted to be a but chunk I could have
taken my gun out of the trash and
mounted a campaign to try and be the VP
pick with the hopes that Gary would quit
but that's just you know you know again
a jerks yeah I already would have been
labeled a jerk so I'm trying to get away
from that so my last question to you at
the end of this is going to be about
2020 but but as a lead-in to that then
so though you learned that lesson there
so do you think you would do things
differently next time before you even
tell me if 2022 no please yes I would
definitely do things differently and you
know there are certain things that you
learn from the process you know
hindsight is 20/20 but I think that
tactically I made some mistakes but
print from a principled perspective I
did everything right raised money the
grassroots way online you know just
doing live streams and going around the
country I think we raised $120,000 so so
in a lot of ways my campaign pioneer the
many of the campaign's in the future for
people who have no power right people
like you are grassroots who can come out
of nowhere I think I showed that people
who are sincere committed activists can
can do that yeah so there are some
things that I would do differently but
most of it's just sort of parliamentary
kind of procedure things yeah how much
for you as an outsider running on an
outsider ticket was about raising money
because that to me is the root of all
the problems right now well you know
what the funny thing was was I thought
about raising money is that when things
are good and you're happy and like
you're doing well you know people will
send you money but there's nothing that
raises money like controversy and one
thing that happened to me and it's so
ironic because I was just their keynote
speaker this year now the Colorado
libertarian party disinvited me from
their debate and I was in Illinois at
the time and I'm there with my my staff
and they said okay well you're not
invited because I disagree with some of
the radical anarchists on one of the Bay
philosophical principle so they're like
oh you're not a libertarian you're not
invited yes what principle is it's
called being the NAP the N AP the
non-aggression principle which many
libertarians believe that is the
centerpiece of libertarian philosophy
which I in no uncertain terms completely
reject simply because in my mind I
believe it leads one to a form a strict
form of pacifism which which doesn't
account for self-defense which they
dispute but aggression being a sort of a
term that can be broadly used in many
ways like what do you different define
its aggression
it leads ones that consider maybe we'll
need a court system to suss it out which
would imply a government which would end
the arguments for Anarchy right they
look and they disagree and they're gonna
be very mad at me for saying that but so
you're taking in that specific in is
what you would argue is just a more
realistic approach or a more functional
Pro not really so it's not a matter of
realism essentially it's a matter of
real true principle yeah simply because
many people have argued in poor this is
going to make people mad but enemy and
the concept of putting this on youtube
right now like YouTube comments well
yeah I think anything beloved we have
your liberal friends go like it kind of
a heretic and libertarian circles for
this yeah but simply many libertarians
have argued and many have told me
directly to my face that the evil of
government is is so horrible that it's
better that we have a society where it
may be immoral to allow a child to
starve to death but it's not illegal
simply because it's all about the
initiation of force right I like to play
the the puzzle gaming if you walk past a
homeless person on the street they're
starving to death and you don't feed
them have you committed a crime
no have you initiated force no you have
a child and it's your child and by
neglect you allow that child to starve
to death have you commit a crime yes and
you initiated force No so that is that's
really where it comes down to the rights
of children is sort of where we start
talking about whether or not some third
party may have a right to come in but
that controversy was enough to make the
libertarian part of Colorado saying no
and it made my activists so angry that
they started pouring money Mike offer
saying Austin Drive to Colorado right
now and we drove all night thirteen
hours straight to the convention took
second place you know beat up on Gary a
little bit
and raise money so yeah that that's
fascinating because this the infighting
of all the parties I find incredible
like just the ability inability for
anyone to build a bridge these days
which is so much of what I'm not a
political insider but what I'm trying to
do around here is build some bridges and
show people you can disagree on abortion
and we'll talk about that a little bit
and bunch of different things and still
find some basic principles right to
believe in but let's just talk about the
general role of government because
that's really what this all comes down
to so you touch on it just a little bit
up top give me the basic things that you
believe government should exist or the
specifics not just not just the ideas of
liberty and that's everything so the
libertarianism isn't really about
government it's about self government so
it's the concept that that you if you
have a just if you have a moral just
society then people should be self
governed and so it's different from the
sort of FDR definition of freedom
because FDR and the Social Democrats
believe that freedom means freedom from
want so you're not free if you're hungry
that's their definition so the question
really comes down to is is that we as
libertarians have a different concept of
freedom from most people because our
concept of freedom is the most
politically incorrect because it
requires personal responsibility and
when you start talking to people about
personal responsibility that's when I
get angry because as and even
libertarians aren't perfect when it
comes down to this but when when it
comes to the actual role of government
it should be the absolute minimum that
is required in order to sustain life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness now
that's the Declaration of Independence
that's not the law but the Constitution
being the law it has very specific
enumerated powers and sometimes
conservatives I think make a mistake
where they'll say well we believe in
states rights and the libertarian says
no actually it's a misnomer only people
have rights you know states have powers
and the idea is that those powers should
be strictly limited and enumerated so we
delegate some of our some of our power
to government but we don't delegate any
of our rights to government our rights
are intrinsic all rights are natural
they are self-evident as to our humanity
and and so libertarian simply believed
that the individual should be self
governed governed to us to the greatest
extent possible until that self
governance is a problem right if you do
not police yourself you will be policed
so in order so as long as you know
whatever action that you're taking isn't
it creates some negative externality on
the community in that question you know
when it comes to the environment right
whether you may be polluting or
something like that these are problems
with libertarians face yeah we believe
in a strict definition of property
rights
so essentially what government should do
is it should you know adjudicate
disputes between property rights holders
and it should prosecute criminal cases
you know force and fraud really it's
what it should do and that's that's
really the limited role of government so
you would take like sanitation away from
the government you would take the US
Postal Service all of those kinds of
things look were we're keeping courts
yeah we're Seafarer we're keeping cops
and then we need nuclear weapons in my
opinion yeah but but that's cops course
new yeah cops course in nuclear I think
we just came up with your slogan for a
cyber in 2020 there I gave me please
yeah how is any of this different do you
consider yourself an Objectivist action
I mean I flirt with it now I'm going to
really get you in trouble good I know
you know I've mentioned Iran people go
nuts I like a lot of it and I've had
many people your own Brook who his books
right over there
right I think that she she rejects
altruism I get a joy out of doing
something I know she argument is is that
well if you get a joy of doing it for
other good people within it selfish it's
not entirely selfish I mean I I think
that you know that there is a there is a
desire for us to sacrifice ourselves in
order to do it for the greater good
some people think that the government
should require that sacrifice on it's
like mandatory service but as a
libertarian I believe in voluntary
service a voluntary military and if I
were to if I had served in the military
I would be doing it out of a sense of
patriotism which would be in some sense
a sense of selflessness and many people
have been drafted right but a lot of
people who fought in World War two
against the Nazis were doing it because
they were fighting for their family or
were fighting out of a greater sense of
one
so I mean I sometimes libertarians ethic
objectives are sort of immune to that
but but not all libertarians are some
libertarians do what they do out of the
sense of what's good for the community I
maybe it's maybe this is what Iran would
say with selfish but I actually do want
to see humanity flourish and thrive I
just simply don't believe the government
is the best way for us to do that yeah
so I don't see actually a major
distinction there from from what you
would believe as opposed to an
Objectivist because doing for yourself
what is selfishly good I always view
that as that's not necessary going to
hurt your neighbor because if you're
smart you're doing what's good for you
you're not going to be dumping in your
neighbors lawn because you want your
neighbor to be happy too but like
sometimes don't you just do good things
for people even it doesn't benefit you I
mean yeah it may make you feel good but
every once in a while I catch myself
just doing things for people like
opening a door handing a quarter to a
homeless person right writing so many my
phone to use or something like that just
not big and I go sometimes I don't
derive any pleasure from and I just do
it automatically right so then that's
then we're on the philosophical piece
that is that somehow actually for you
which it does almost to me it's almost
irrelevant in a sort of real world right
right the county probably my biggest
issue with like Objectivist is just
simply the again that it it's just
tasteful to me because I really dislike
culture personality mm-hmm I and and I
just I'm the contrarian and a skeptic
and I just really like to pick things
apart find the flaws in it you know this
is what gets you in trouble and it gets
you branded a heretic but you know when
you find flaws and you want to pull the
the thread eventually this sweater comes
apart just because I like to see what
things are made of right and I don't
like to accept things just because this
Murray Rothbard said it or I'll and set
it right or Ron Paul said it you know
now I just angered the everybody else we
should I normally don't have a list of
people to anger but I feel like I should
have had a little you know Glenn Beck
whiteboard here and I could just we have
not all we haven't we haven't hit some
as yes you have an occasion but we'll
get there
[Music]
you